he's under contract for three more years
you can ask joe tomorrow
do you want him you can ask joe tomorrow
i'm not the personal
uncharted
person was adam gay season ending press
conference uh
that created a story you know and it was
explained to me that gase was extra
salty because it was manish meadow the
new york daily news and there's kind of
a thing between the two of them so uh uh
gates did get criticized for being a
little uh what's his new name what's his
name manisha's new name
what are you talking about what's his
burner account on twitter that's not
that's all that's that's all unconfirmed
so we're not gonna go down that okay
we're not gonna go down that path uh
something like ryan or i know i can't
thank you because everybody was tweeting
at him thanks
that was the name yeah anytime he would
for a while there any time he would
tweet something the response would be
what whatever the name was on the the
what it was supposed to be an adam gase
burner account it was made to look like
it was a gas burner account there was
speculation that manish actually set it
up but it's all been unconfirmed and
uncorroborated and that's water under
the under the bridge
but we still need to determine what's
going to happen with le'veon bell in
2020. he believes he's still going to be
a jet he said everybody's blowing
everything out of proportion water under
the bridge maybe i i didn't mean to use
that term twice in 30 seconds we're fine
we're good jets for four more years
unless something drastic changes here's
the thing though he acknowledged that
they had trade talks teams like the
texans and the chiefs and the packers
and the steelers had contacted the jets
and the only reason it didn't happen and
he admitted this to me we interviewed
him during the season that he wasn't
willing to adjust his contract if he'd
been willing to adjust his contract he'd
have been traded so
uh we have more time in the offseason a
greater opportunity for teams to to
inquire and and try to work something
out where maybe le'veon bell does take
less or maybe the jets pay some of it to
unload him i wouldn't be stunned if he
ends up back in pittsburgh chris i i you
know what you're right i think that's
the one place i look at and go
i could see that happening and then yes
you're right jets may be paying part of
the salary it's going to have to be
something like that you know the jets
are backed into a corner here yeah they
signed le'veon bell to
you know a contract that's probably a
little too rich le'veon bell is
certainly not going to make an
adjustment to his contract no i mean
he's he's got all the leverage at least
for one more year right i mean i'm
looking at his salary uh guaranteed
right 13 and a half million guarantees
they let him go with 17 million dollars
in dead money so they're not going to
let that happen now i will say this
first off i do think adam gates still
likes le'veon bell you know i think
i think where this one wrong is adam
gayes has friends in the nfl and i think
he paid too much exactly that's where i
was going he realized from people he
talked to that they probably paid like
four or five million dollars a year more
than what levion was being offered per
year and i don't think that sat well
with them but i also will say i don't
think they used le'veon bell to his full
capabilities last year either and that
adam gase could certainly continue to
expand that offense and maybe ride him a
little harder in the run game le'veon
bell is one of those runners where as
the game goes on he gets better and
better he's a big human being like derek
henry not as big as derek henry but a
big guy and i know that's the thing when
i saw him in person on the field that
was the one thing i was taking backup by
yeah he's got all the quick moves and
could do that but man when he wants to
run you over he can run you over he's
got power to his game and i don't know
if he was necessarily putting those
positions all year long let alone hey
the jets you know they were kind of all
over the place as a team to begin with
uh with sam darnold and everything he
had to deal with and mono and all that
yeah and you know
um pittsburgh is an interesting one
though mike you're you're right i do
still look at them as maybe being a
player in this le'veon bell thing if if
the jets decide they do want to move
another direction
and let's say that the chiefs decide to
kick the can for a year and not resign
patrol homes until 2021 they were one of
the teams yeah that le'veon bell
identified as talking to the jets about
a trade would that not be something talk
about the rich getting richer sorry
damian williams we've got le'veon bell
and that's one area on the team all due
respect to damian williams that's one
area on the team where the chiefs could
try to upgrade because that position
hasn't been the same since they dumped
kareem hunt and they still won a super
bowl without hunt but uh chris i think
whether it's through free agency trade
or the draft you're going to look at the
chiefs trying to upgrade the running
back position for 2020. uh yeah i would
think you're right there yes uh you know
lashawn mccoy it's it's coming to an end
you know you're not going to depend on
him to be a bell cow guy damian williams
good very good don't don't get me wrong
uh but yes you know i think they're
going to try to continue to look for
that guy like they had in kareem hunt
who really yeah he was a runner but you
could line karine kareem hub hunt in in
the slot right and he's one of those
guys like a levy on bell you put him in
the slot and he's really as good as the
slot receiver running routes and doing
things that way too and those are tough
matchups for defenses and dealing with
that and the personnel sets to go along
with it so uh yes and kansas city hey
they just won a super bowl through their
offense average defense great offense i
think they're going to continue to what
you're saying mike to make sure that
part of their team is great and they can
win games with mahomes and andy reid
you can keep damian williams to the
total compensation package for this year
2.3 million oh my god that's pretty damn
williams right keep him le'veon bell
that's a hell of a one-two punch if they
would decide to go that route and you
know we've talked about the 49ers
upgrading the chiefs are going to be
looking to upgrade too but not at
quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports